ADDY BROWN: Good afternoon,
and welcome to another Google
Authors event.
Today, we feature a Googler.
We have Gopi Kallayil,
featuring his new book,
"The Internet to the Inner-Net."
My name is Addy Brown,
and I'm the head
of the industry on health
insurance in San Francisco,
and I'm honored to be
opening for Gopi here today.
Gopi and I go way back, having
worked on several summits
together, and now
we're coming up
on our 10-year Googleversary.
He and I have been
friends for a long time.
I want to share with
you a quick story on how
this book came to life for me.
I was out to dinner a
couple weeks ago with Gopi,
and while I was waiting
for him, I sat at the bar
and finished up the last
couple of chapters of his book.
The couple next to me took an
interest in what I was reading,
having seen the
title of the chapter,
"Attitude of Gratitude."
Now, this couple was very
skeptical of this type of book,
so it took me a few minutes
to explain to them why
this content and author
were so relevant, timely,
and different.
Now they just couldn't
wait to meet Gopi.
Within two minutes
of Gopi's arrival,
he had them and half
the bar, including
the bartender, engaged
in a lively activity
around attitude.
I ended up gifting my
book to this couple,
and I've since heard
from them on how special
and changing this
event was for them.
True Gopi magic in action.
From be the bison, to be the
ice cube, to be grateful,
this book helps free your mind
from the Times Square world
that we live in today
and really helps
you take back
control of the things
that you have control over, like
your attitude and perspective.
I know Gopi doesn't
need any introduction
inside of these walls, but
let me refresh your memory
as to why he is so talented and
why we are so lucky to have him
here today.
Gopi is the chief brand
evangelist at Google.
He works with the sales
teams and customers
to help grow customer brands
through digital marketing.
Before joining Google, Gopi
was the management team
of two Silicon Valley
venture-funded startups
and a consultant at McKinsey.
He also led large information
technology projects
for global corporations in
India, China, and the US.
He earned his bachelor's
in electronics engineering
from the National Institute
of Technology in India.
He received his MBAs from the
Indian Institute of Management
and the Wharton
School of Business.
He is an avid yoga practitioner,
triathlete, public speaker,
global traveler, and
Burning Man devotee.
His most recent
passion is music,
and he has just released
his first album.
I also just learned
that he answers
every single email in his
inbox-- truly incredible.
Please welcome my
dear friend, Gopi.
[APPLAUSE]
GOPI KALLAYIL: Thank you.
Speaking of an
attitude of gratitude,
how appropriate that I
get introduced by Addy,
a dear friend at Google
for many years ago,
and her name could very well
have been attitude as well,
given what a positive
outlook to life
she always represents for me.
I want to start out with
a question for all of you.
How many organs are
there in your body?
20?
Any other guesses?
How many organs?
It's incredible, right, to know
we're sitting there wondering,
puzzled?
Even though this is
instrument or tool
we all use every single day,
and we're not even sure.
I wasn't sure either, so I asked
some doctor friends of mine,
and they pondered
about it a while,
and they said we're not sure.
It all depends on
how you count organs.
So then I went to my most
trusted source, Ms. Google,
and Ms. Google told me there
are 78 organs in the human body
by popular consensus among
medical practitioners,
and the largest
of that being the
AUDIENCE: Skin.
GOPI KALLAYIL: Skin,
yeah, largest organ.
I want to introduce you
today to this 79th organ that
is now available to us,
not created by nature,
not created by
some higher power,
depending on your belief
system, but created entirely
by human beings-- this
little device here.
And does that kind of shock
you that I'm addressing this
as the 79th organ in the body?
But in many ways, it's started
behaving like a human organ.
It has a skin.
You touch it.
It responds.
It has eyes.
It recognizes objects,
faces around you.
It has ears.
You speak to it.
It understands you.
It has a voice because
it can talk back at you,
talk at you sometimes.
And clearly, it seems to have
this enormous mental brain
power because this tiny 79th
organ in the palm of your hands
is connected to all published
publicly available human wisdom
out there through
the internet and can
answer practically
any factual question
that you are searching for.
And it must have a mind, spirit,
and consciousness of some level
because otherwise, why
else would all of us
walk around with our 79th
so close to our heart,
sleep with it next
to our bedside?
How many of you do that?
OK, about half the room.
And most importantly, you
go anywhere on this campus,
or practically walk around
any city in the world today,
you'll find people with the 79th
organ lost deeply in prayer.
But all jokes apart, it's
technologies like this
that has become so pervasive.
The numbers are astonishing.
This past February, we reached
a unique point in human history.
There are now an
estimated 7.2 billion
mobile devices and 7.1
billion human beings.
For the first time
in history, we
have a technology that exceeds
the number of human beings,
and that puts us at
this unique inflection
point in human history with a
lot of implications, some of it
really powerful, positive
impact that it has had,
this kind of pervasiveness
of this technology,
and sometimes completely
unintended, unexpected kind
of consequences.
Let me give you an
example of the first one.
Three years ago, I decided
to visit the largest
gathering of humanity, a
festival called the Kumbh Mela.
It's a festival that
takes place in India
on the banks of the
river Ganga [INAUDIBLE]
with the other confluence.
And it's a festival that
attracts 100 million people--
100 million people-- over the 51
days the festival takes place.
In fact, on the day
when I got there,
there were 31 million people.
And in India, when
they say there
were millions of
people at a festival,
it is not a figure of speech.
It means there were
actually millions
of people gathered there.
That was what 30 million on a
single day on the banks of one
river looks like.
Now, this festival is
famous for attracting
a lot of Hindu holy
men-- spiritualists,
monks, yogis, mystics.
These are career professionals
who have dedicated their lives
to exploring the inner journey.
They spend a bulk of
the time in practices
like meditation and
silence and contemplation,
which is interesting.
So early one morning, as walking
along the banks of the river
as the sun was coming up, and
I spotted one of these mystics
on the banks of the river.
And this person, he was
not engaged in a yoga pose.
As the sun was coming up, he
was not lost deep in meditation.
He was not chanting
Sanskrit mantras.
Instead, he was jabbering
away on a cell phone,
and I was thinking, what
is he doing this morning?
Who is he talking to, Lord
Shiva his venture capitalist?
And I was thinking, what are we
doing with the technologies we
build here, driving
to distraction
these professional meditators?
But all jokes apart, it is true
that these kind of technologies
have really put us in an amazing
amount of power and capability
in our hands, and
I want to tell you
one story where it illustrates
deeply the extent to which
it is touching human
lives around the planet
in a positive way.
And for that, I actually
want to take you
to a tiny rice farming
village called Chittilamchery
in southern India.
And I took this photograph
three weeks ago, four weeks ago.
I was there.
And this is a place that
has a very, very soft spot
in my heart because
this is my home village.
This is where my parents were.
This were the pictures I took
as I went down memory lane
and looked at the
green paddy fields
that my grandfather
used to grow rice in
and visiting the village
temple and befriending again
the current local resident
village elephant, et cetera.
So it had a very, very
sweet experience for me
as I went through.
And the reason I feel this
strong sense of connection
with this particular
village, and where
this connection with
technology becomes
really vivid in my mind, is
if I go back several years ago
and look at this
rice paddies, they
are the same rice paddies
that fed our families.
And this is where
my grandparents
lived their entire life
as poor rice farmers.
And this is the same village
where my parents also
grew up as the children
of poor rice farmers,
with a very modest
kind of background
that you get to experience
in a rural Indian village.
So they grew up
without electricity.
They grew up without
running water.
And the only education
that they have
is a modest 10
years of schooling
in the local Indian
rural village school.
And yet, they created the
circumstances and conditions
for their kids, me
and my three siblings,
and we went on to get 10
advanced degrees, including
two from US Ivy League
business schools,
even though my parents had
never set foot in America.
So often, the question
is asked, "What
caused that kind of social
mobility in one generation?"
It was simply access
to information.
But it's very slow access.
I still remember after
graduating from engineering
school when I wanted to get
information on graduate schools
to apply to, I took an
eight-hour train trip
from the town where our college
was to the nearest big city
of Chennai to get access to the
only physical copy I knew where
I could get us access
to of the "US World News
Guide to Graduate Schools."
Eight-hour train journey.
Now, of course, we pull
out the 79th organ,
and if it takes eight
seconds, it seems forever.
We get restless about it.
But it was still
access to information
that really changed
the family's trajectory
and caused that kind
of social mobility.
So when I went back this
time four weeks ago,
I looked at the school
where my mother studied.
In terms of
infrastructure, it does not
look very different
from 30, 40 years ago,
but for one difference.
In that school And tens
of thousands of schools
like that around the world--
it's not just in this village,
but any part of
the world that you
can look at-- kids with
access to computers
and the kind of
amazing technologies
that we are building
and the information
we are putting on top
of it now have access
to the same amount
of information
as you all currently
have sitting here
or somebody has at the top
universities in the world.
So clearly, thanks
to this technologies,
in an era where
information is like oxygen,
we are leveling the playing
field for information.
Huge amounts of
benefit, and all of us
are participants in creating
that kind of an ecosystem.
And it's really transformed
life on this planet.
All well and good, but that
puts us also in direct conflict
with something else
that we fundamentally
need as human beings,
and that is what I want
to examine in this talk today.
On the one hand, so I say--
I illustrated with this two
examples, these technologies
are playing an amazing role,
but it also comes at a
certain kind of price,
the price for attention, the
price to-- the distraction
that it brings to our life.
And we're all trying to cope
with the amount of information
that comes because all of these
technologies-- they constantly
clamor for attention.
We have to respond to
the hundreds of emails
that come to us, the pings,
the rings, the tweets.
And it is around the clock.
There is no question.
The old rhythm of life--
when the sun goes down,
you turn things off.
Automatically,
everything shut down,
and your body and
the pace of life
slow down-- that is
simply not possible
because around the clock,
it is daylight somewhere,
and somebody is trying to
contact you and communicate
with you, and you
feel that urge,
that irresistible urge to
want to respond to that.
And that puts us in this very,
very paradoxical situation,
and that is these
technologies are useful.
We need to respond to them.
We need to work with them.
But they constantly
seek our attention.
And yet, there are these other
technologies that we use,
which I'll talk about in a
minute, that seem to need
a different kind of response.
So before I go to that, let's
not forget one simple fact.
Right now, even as
internet technologies
are playing an amazingly
useful role in our lives,
most people still do
not have access to them.
I know it's kind of hard for us
to comprehend and believe that.
We've gotten so much used to it.
But even now, a
full-fledged access
to internet and
internet-based services
is available only to an
estimated 2.5 to 3 billion
people, which means
most people in the world
do not have access to it.
And even in the midst of
that kind of digital divide
we're trying to address,
there is one technology
that is universally available
to every single human
being on this planet, all
7.1 billion human beings.
We use it every single
day, and I still
think of it as the most
sophisticated, most complex
piece of technology that
we know of, and what is it?
Yeah, our brain, right?
Our brain, our body, our
breath, our consciousness--
and with a tongue-in-cheek
kind of way,
I'm calling that
as a technology.
And I address this as the
most sophisticated kind
of technology.
And using just a simple example
[INAUDIBLE] come to light.
Noga, how old is
your daughter now?
AUDIENCE: Almost two.
GOPI KALLAYIL: Two, right?
She's learning language, right?
And she's learning three
languages simultaneously,
right?
Hebrew, English, and?
AUDIENCE: A little
bit of Spanish.
GOPI KALLAYIL: A
little bit of Spanish.
And this three-year-old
does not have
to be taught complex rules
of grammar in each language.
Somehow, they pick it up.
Why are these sounds and words?
And if you just watch that
itself, it is fascinating.
We're not even
close to replicating
that kind of behavior in any
of these technologies created.
And that's why I said
this still continues
to be one of the most
sophisticated, complex piece
of technologies, and we
get to use-- not only
do we get to use it
every single day.
I had this moment
of epiphany when
there was a teacher from
India who came here to Google,
and during a lunch, his
name is [INAUDIBLE].
He made this point.
He said your entire life
experience will be filtered
through this technology.
Think about that for a minute.
Your entire life experience-- so
right now, Noga's having lunch,
and that lunch is being
processed by this technology.
You're sitting here listening
to this conversation with me,
and if you're trying
to make sense of it,
it is being processed
by this technology.
Before we started, I
played a piece of music
by the Toure-Raichel Collective.
And if the music had an
emotional impact on you,
and that is because it went
through this technology,
left some kind of an imprint
on your internal system,
and either made your heart race
or made your mind calm down.
So anything you
experience in this life
is being filtered by
this inner technologies,
and the quality of
your life is determined
by the quality of how this
technology is maintained
in the state of peak performance
and optimal performance.
And if you are trying to
comprehend what exactly
do you mean by that,
think of the time
when you last had, say, the
flu, a simple thing that might
have passed in six, seven days.
But the minute your
body state changes you
to a flu, all of a sudden,
your favorite food,
you don't want to eat.
You don't want to be
with your friends.
The music that you might
have otherwise enjoyed--
all of a sudden, you want
to shut it down and curl
under a blanket because
something shifted
in this inner technologies.
And therefore, there is the
simple fact and realization
that struck me, that
the quality of our life
is determined by the quality
of this inner technologies.
And this is where
the intersection
with these kind of
technologies and what
this inner technology needs
puts us in direct conflict.
So on the one hand, all of this
needs your constant attention,
and you need to react quickly.
And you might be distracted,
or your attention
might be fragmented.
But for this technology to be
in a state of peak performance,
it needs its moments of quiet.
It seems to need its
moments of withdrawal
and a little bit of
spaciousness in your life.
So how do you bring those
two things together?
So periodically, you need, as
I in a fun way refer to it--
you need to unplug
from the internet,
and on a regular places--
unplug from the internet,
and on a regular basis
plug into your inner net.
So thought about
this long and hard,
and how do you make
it work, especially
for people in this
audience who live
in this part of the
world in Silicon Valley
and work in an
industry like this,
and as I jokingly
tell my friends,
are actually actively
involved in creating more
weapons of mass distraction?
So how do you make these
things come together?
And this is where in the book,
I talk about some rituals
that I've tried-- experimented--
that seem to work for me.
So among the 32 chapters, I
explore at least one idea.
How do you stay connected
with the internet while still
taking full advantage of all
of these outer technologies?
So the one thing I
want to be clear here,
there are lots of advice
and books you'll find,
and people talking
about it, but here, I'm
not advocating by any
stretch of the imagination
jettisoning these
kind of technologies.
I'm not asking you to go on a
retreat off to a zen monastery
somewhere.
I'm saying stay plugged in.
Have full engagement
with the life
as it happens
around you, and yet
carve out a little bit of
space, some kind of ritual
that on a daily basis you
are able to practice in order
to plug into your inner net.
So of the different
techniques I talk
about, let me explore
five of them with you,
and if we have
time, maybe even go
into a little bit of
a practice session.
So the first one I urge readers
in this book to consider
is to focus on the essential.
So as German
philosopher Goethe said,
things that are more
important should not
be at the mercy of things
that are less important.
Things that are more
important should not
be at the mercy of things
that are less important.
And the benefit
of knowing clearly
what your top priorities,
what the essentials are,
then gives you an opportunity,
as the demands on your life
ask you to fragment your
attention over many things--
you can say yes to a
few of those essentials
and say no most of the other
things that may be distracting
you because then you're
very clear how you choose
to spend your time, your
life energy, and what
you choose to spend it on.
So how many essentials
do you need?
I would say start with one.
Have a clear idea what your
most important core essential
is, maybe three.
In my case, I have five.
And I'll tell you how
I arrived at the five.
Years ago, I was involved with a
Silicon Valley startup company,
and it was a very stressful,
highly demanding time
of my life.
Most of my waking hours were
spent on building the company,
up on the business plan,
raising funding, et cetera.
And when it got to a point when
the stress was a bit too much,
I felt I needed a break, so I
left with a dear friend of mine
to spend a weekend
in a retreat center
in a monastery on the Big Sur
coast called the New Camaldoli
Dali Hermitage.
It's a Benedictine
monastery, and the 11 monks
who stay there own a little
bit of income for the monastery
by having these cottages,
where you can go and stay
that everyone-- one person
stays in one cottage overlooking
the Pacific Ocean
or the mountains--
a beautiful setting.
And the idea is that
while you're there,
you spend most of your time in
a silent, contemplative kind
of state.
So they provided the
facility to do that.
And what I also found amusing is
that these are fairly reclusive
monks, busy with their
practice, but their URL
is www.contemplation.com.
And how a bunch of reclusive
monks did internet squatting
and grabbed a killer
URL in their category
just boggles my mind,
but they did it.
They have www.contemplation.com.
So I was staying
in this monastery
and spent the weekend
mostly in silence
because that's what they
encourage you to do.
It gave me a chance to
step back and reflect.
And it struck me
while I was there
that my startup has
a business plan,
but I have no business
plan for my life.
I have no business
So I spend the
entire weekend saying
I'm going to write one down.
I call it a business plan, but
something that comes to a close
equal.
You might call it
mission statement.
I call it the organizing
principles of my life.
Essentially, I was
asking the question,
what are the top
essentials for my life?
And I was also very insistent
it should not be too detailed.
It should not be too complex.
I don't need to write a
whole 30-page essay about it.
It should fit on
one sheet of paper,
and that should be the case,
I recommend, for all of us.
What is truly
important in life, we
should be able to articulate
on one sheet of paper.
And I wasn't satisfied
with that process.
Having got it down
to a sheet of paper,
I wanted to reduce
it even further.
I wanted to get it down to
its pure, beautiful essence,
and I reduced it to five words.
So about 14 years ago,
I did this exercise.
And for these 14
years since then,
I carry around these five
words, metaphorically
speaking on my fingertips so
that at any point in time where
a million things call
for my attention,
I always go back to those five
essentials and ask myself,
am I spending my time,
attention, energy on those five
essentials so that I can say
no to most of the other things
that are distractions?
So that's one of
the first things
I would encourage you to do.
Ask yourself as you leave,
if you already don't know it,
what are your essentials?
Using that as a starting
point, the second ritual
on a daily basis in the
midst of all of this frenzy
I ask you to practice is
to do one thing at a time.
Now, there is nothing sacred
about this particular device.
This is something that you've
been hearing all your life.
Your grandma told
you this, and this
is the equivalent of
saying that if you
eat vegetables and
exercise regularly,
you will be healthier.
But this reason I felt that
we needed to reset and revisit
is despite knowing this, when
it comes to actual practice,
we seem to be struggling as
a species, as a generation.
So last week, I was
passing through an airport,
and I saw this woman in front
of me in the security line.
And tell me if
you either seen it
or you've personally
done something like this.
So she was moving forward
in the security line,
and she was pushing
her bag with her feet
because her hands were occupied.
So she was pushing a
little-- sorry, with her leg.
And she was speaking
on the phone.
She also had lunch in her hand.
So she's pushing the bag,
speaking on the phone,
her lunge in her hand,
when the caller asked
for some piece of
information, and she
said, let me get it for you.
She now cradled it,
pulled her tablet,
and was looking up
information with one thumb
with the sandwich in the hand.
She got up to the security desk,
and the gentleman, the security
officer, asked for her
boarding pass and documents.
And she sat the iPad down,
reached into her wallet,
pulled it, gave it to him, and
then went back to the iPad.
And this time, she was doing
five things at the same time.
And I looked at it
and said how did we
get here as a civilization?
How have we survived
as a species?
And I look back on my own
life and said, often, this
is the way I am behaving.
It is the curse of what
blogger Linda Stone calls
continuous partial attention,
continuous partial attention
on three different things.
And I often catch
myself, and I have
to be very aware and conscious
of this, sitting in meetings
trying to pay attention to
what somebody is presenting
and discussing, while
at the same time
I'm trying to answer an email.
I have three chat windows
open, and simultaneously trying
to get through lunch as well.
At the end of the meeting, if
you ask me what was discussed,
I only have a little
bit of an idea
because I wasn't
paying full attention.
If you ask me how did the food
taste because you had lunch,
I couldn't tell you because
I was just mechanically
wolfing it down.
And often probably send the
wrong embarrassing text message
in the wrong window.
She did forgive me.
So this is how we
end up carrying on
on a day-to-day basis, and
it comes at a certain price
because this technology,
the brain and our body,
is extremely good if you
ask it to do one task.
And you try to make it do
five tasks at the same time,
it completely falls apart.
But when I talk about
this, a lot of people
today argue that no, an
entire generation of people
are coming up.
They have become extremely
good at multitasking.
If that is the case,
I would ask you this.
How many of you would
be willing to go
into-- if you had to--
open-heart surgery
where the surgeon says, "I'm
really good at multitasking.
And while I'm operating
on you, I like baseball.
I like the stock market.
I'm going to have the
TV on with both channels
and just pay attention to that."
How come, if you're so
comfortable that we have become
a generation of
multitaskers-- how many of you
ever seen a virtuoso
musician practicing
on the cello, the violin,
while watching a game on TV
simultaneously?
So if you look at any
example of peak performance
in any discipline, there is
a single-pointed attention
that has been
brought to the task,
and that is what I'm
urging you to consider.
At least catch yourself when
your attention is fragmented
and come back to
the simple ritual
of do one thing at a time
because that puts this
into a state of
peak performance.
And more importantly,
your energy level changes.
When it's fragmented,
when you're
jumping between three
things, it exhausts you very,
very quickly.
The third ritual that I
talk about in this book
is commit yourself to at
least one minute of connection
with your inner-net.
Just one minute.
How many minutes
are there in a day,
math wizards in the audience?
1,440.
OK, there are 1,440 minutes.
Take at least one
of those minutes
to just give yourself, the
most important technology,
your fullest attention
with whatever practice
that may help you get there.
So I'm not advocating
any particular one.
In my own case,
yoga and meditation
are two of my practices
just to unplug from it all
and plug into my inner-net.
This morning, I did it
before going to work.
A few minutes of yoga, a
few minutes of meditation,
it sets the tone for the day.
So at this point,
you're sitting there
thinking, one minute of yoga.
That's such a ridiculous idea.
What can you get
done in one minute?
This is nonsense.
But I'll tell you how I arrived
at this particular decision
and the kind of
impact it has had.
So years ago, after I spent
some time in an Indian ashram
and become a yoga teacher,
during the time of my training,
every day I did four hours
of physical yoga on a mat.
I spent an hour meditating,
plus many other practices.
It was really incredible on
the kind of mental mind shift
that I experienced during
the time I was there.
I was in college at the time.
I left that place
with this commitment
saying I am going
to commit myself
to doing this every single
day, meaning every single day,
I'm going to practice at
least one hour of yoga and 30
minutes of meditation.
And how long did that last?
Three days.
I went back to
college, and my life
had been completely taken
over by staying up till 3 AM,
partying with
friends, and listening
to Led Zeppelin and Pink Floyd.
So for years, I struggled,
and I kept failing.
I kept falling off the wagon.
Most days, I could not
live up to my commitment.
And I joined Google.
I came here, and I'm still
struggling many years later.
The fact that I didn't
seem to have integrity
towards my practice-- when I
went and talked to Meng one
day-- Meng, as many of
you-- probably everybody
in the audience knows, the
esteemed and famous author
of the book "Search
Inside Yourself."
So Meng looked at me and
said, "Gopi, why don't you
start with one breath?
Because even if you're trying
to meditate for a full hour,
it's really 600 breaths
strung together.
You have to get past
your first breath
before you get to the
rest of your practice."
And since I'm a compulsive,
neurotic overachiever,
I said I can do
better than that.
I commit myself
to a whole minute.
So that is what led to this
commitment of one minute
every single day.
But here's what
happened magically.
Now, there was not
a single day where
I could argue with
myself, saying, oh, I
don't have the time, because
my brain would say if you can't
give yourself one minute,
one minute of the 1,440,
to nurturing your inner-net,
this technology, what
is the point of living?
So that became easy.
It was a hurdle that I crossed,
and now a week went by.
Two weeks went by.
Six weeks went by.
And for the first
time, I could look back
and claim, legitimately,
that hey, I
did yoga and meditation
every single day, even
if it was for one minute.
So the idea here is
whatever that you're
trying to do to form
that inner connection,
find the lowest possible
threshold that you
can't say no on a daily basis,
and commit yourself to it.
But then, what I
was not prepared
for is the magic that
unfolded down the line, which
is on many days,
I would sit down
for maybe a minute of
meditation or for a minute
of yoga practice.
And then it would go by.
I would feel so good internally
that the quest would pop up.
What else is out there that is
so much more important that I'm
rushing off to?
This feels so wonderful,
even this one minute
that I've committed,
that I would
go to the second minute,
the third minute.
And before long, it was
so easy to get into a 20-,
30-minute kind of practice.
So something shifted
there, and this is really
what I'm asking you to
engineer, by starting
with a single,
one-minute commitment.
So again, as part
of this exercise
as you sit here and listen,
I'm asking you to think about,
what is that one minute,
every single day,
on a regular, disciplined
basis, that you're
going to commit to to find that
connection with your inner-net?
The fourth ritual that I want to
talk about, creating some kind
of a weekly appointment for
connecting to your inner-net.
So there are 168 hours in
the week, and most of us,
given our personal
life, professional life,
feel that we don't have that
much control over our schedule.
It gets hijacked all the time as
people add meetings and demand
us to be doing different
things, which is all true,
which is just one of the
downsides of how technology has
enabled our calendars
to be completely exposed
and managed and manipulated
by other people.
So you feel like my
schedule is out of control.
Other people are dominating
it, taking over it,
asking me to show up
at these meetings.
All well and good.
But of those 116
hours in the week,
commit at least one
hour on a regular slot,
fixed day of the
week, to something
that gives you about
60 minutes of forming
that inner connection.
For me personally,
it is Monday, 5:30.
It's a fixed slot.
I teach yoga to the
yogalers at Google.
And for the 9 and 1/2
years I've been at Google,
I've never missed a single
class unless I'm out
of town, in which case, someone
like [INAUDIBLE] or [INAUDIBLE]
would sub for me.
But for the yogalers community,
we always make it available.
That is like one
commitment's non-negotiable.
And I communicate that.
So I'm asking you to pick one
fixed slot every week that
is sacred to you,
and you communicate
to your people who work with
you, people in your family,
and try to hold that.
So the other rest of
your 167 hours in a week
can completely fall apart.
No problem.
But that one hour you hold
yourself accountable to it.
Simple ritual--
and try it and see
how magic will unfold
as a result of that.
The final piece of the five
that I want to talk about today
is this notion of
friend yourself.
And what I mean by there is
that ever since social media
technology was
available to us, it
has put an amazing amount
of power in our hands
where now we are able to
communicate on a regular basis
to thousands of people
around the world using one
of the social media platforms.
And we even brag to
each other, saying look
at the number of people
who follow me on Twitter.
Look at how many connections
I have on LinkedIn,
or Facebook, or Google Plus.
All well and good.
It definitely has
scaled how much,
how far we can communicate.
But in the midst of all
of this, periodically it's
important to step
back and remember
that the most important
relationship we will ever have
is the one with ourselves.
The most important
relationship you will ever have
is the one with yourself.
So even as in the midst of
how your life gets sucked
into the rhythm of
someone else's life
and you start feeling a
sense of moral inferiority
because everyone
else on social media
is having such an amazing
life on the beaches
that they have traveled to and
the parties that they have gone
to and the festivals
that they are at,
you still find that
connection back to yourself,
that friending.
So metaphorically speaking,
what I'm asking everyone
to think about is
on a regular basis,
listen to the tweet
from your heartbeat.
Listen to the chat
request from your brain,
and listen to the status
update from your body
because there is something
that it is trying to tell you.
And before you get into all
these friend relationship,
ask yourself the question,
have you friended yourself?
So these are the five rituals
that seem to work well for me.
And my main message
here is not exactly--
feel free to replicate these
five, but find your own
three or five on
a regular basis.
And most importantly, just
ask-- examine your life
to the extent
where you say, what
is it that I need to do
on a regular daily basis
to find that connection
to my inner-net?
Because as I started off
and said in the beginning,
the most important
thing that you can do
is to pay attention to
this inner technology
because everything
you'll experience,
you have experienced
in life so far
and that you'll
experience going forward,
is being filtered by this
particular technology.
And these rituals help
you move this technology
to stay at a peak performance.
And I want you to leave
this talk asking yourself
the question-- or if you decide
to read the book, triggered
by these ideas--
what are going to be
the rhythm of your life,
the rituals in your life
on a daily basis that
allow you to put your most
important inner technology into
a state of peak performance?
So to give you a little
flavor of what I write about
in this book, I'll just read
a paragraph here and there,
just to get a sense of how
we approach this topic.
And if you have
time, then I'll go
into a little bit
of practice session
as well before closing up.
If all you read is
just the foreword,
then I encourage you to do it.
Pico Iyer, a good friend of mine
who is a very well-known travel
writer, and his most recent book
is called "The Joy of Quiet"--
he's spoken at
Google two times--
he agreed to write the
foreword, and he's an eloquent,
eloquent writer, and
his prose is brilliant.
So if all you do is
just read that foreword,
I encourage you to
because there is
a way by which he
articulates it,
and he said, "If Googlers and
their colleagues in the valley
are the unacknowledged
legislators of tomorrow's
mankind, I thought
we need people
with this rich and
humble sense of something
beyond our ideas and
calculations, high achievers
who know the value of surrender
as much as of control.
"If these Googlers are, in
fact, the new millennium's
first masters of
the universe, let
them be guided a
sense of mystery
as much as mastery,
of unknowingness
of everything we can quantify
as well as everything we can.
Walking around the mega screens
and beach volleyball courts
of the Googleplex
gave me a sense
of the field on which our
new rulers meet and play.
But listening to
the music gave me
hope for something
more lasting,"
and he goes on to say "through
which our engineers can work
on not just our tools, but
of the souls that put them
to best use."
And as part of the introduction,
I went on to-- actually,
Pico then continues, "Yet
what many of his friends
and colleagues are trying
to do even more impressively
is ensure that there is
a space for Walden Pond,
even amidst the digital
wonders and blinking lights
of the Google campus, and that
helping to advance technology
and our sense of
possibility comes
from singing kirtans as much as
from producing spreadsheets."
So one of the stories I
describe in the introduction--
I was driving down-- and I
drive down the 101 every day.
And one day, I suddenly
turned and saw--
I don't know how
many of you notice it
if you come in the direction--
there is a giant Buddha
statue the 101 freeway.
Somebody's installed it.
And I just kind
of-- how many days
had gone past without noticing
it, and it suddenly struck me,
it's right here
in Silicon Valley.
I'm not in Nepal,
or Tibet, or Bhutan.
And what is a giant
Buddha doing here?
And then I started paying
more attention to it
on a daily basis, and I
went on to write in my book.
"On my way to work, I pass
the perfect juxtaposition
of my two worlds.
On the side of highway
101, the main artery
through Silicon Valley, looms
a huge statue of the Buddha.
His back to the industrial
park where he sits,
he smiles at the harried tech
workers hurrying to their jobs
at Google, and
Facebook, and Apple.
I don't know if they
even notice him,
but the Buddha, not
at all concerned
whether he's been
acknowledged or not,
sits with a serene
look on his face,
holding his hands up
as though in blessing.
Go in peace.
Go slowly.
"There is an incongruity to it.
A philosopher from
2,500 years ago who
urged the middle path now
sits along a traffic-clogged
freeway, ferrying
people on their way
to most likely built products
and system that will improve
our lives and connect
us to each other,
yet also add to the frenzy
and deluge of information we
face in our accelerated lives.
When I see the Buddha in
the brief second of turning
my head, I'm
reminded that I need
to pause and reflect
on something larger
than the day's schedule that
currently occupies my mind."
And that is really
the core message
that I'm trying to
deliver through this book,
that on a regular
basis, we all need
to take a few seconds,
a few minutes of time
on a regular basis on every
day, in the midst of all
the clamor of the
rhythm of our life
as to what is it that
is larger than ourselves
that we are trying to do
here, that we connect with,
and how will we realize it.
And then I conclude
in the final chapter
next, where I say, "Such
enormous possibilities
in our lives staring at us.
But to live in this
new world opening
to us, to adapt to the demands
of the world that will emerge,
we need new rules for living.
Our children will
need new rules.
Going forward,
more than ever, we
need to tune into
our inner technology
and bring it into
balance with the outer.
"In many cases, we can
draw on the old ways that
will serve us, the
wisdom traditions
that we benefit from 2,500
years of experimentation, trial
and error by other human
beings who have gone before us.
This is a guide book that
never goes out of date,
yet it is dynamic.
We can build on it, move
forward, or in our world,
in our lives, even though we
can learn from the old ways,
we can't click the Back button.
We have to click Next."
[APPLAUSE]